this is so hard today we are going to be
smiling all day whatever we're doing
we're gonna have a big smile on our face
I don't really think I smiled I try to
avoid it actually I also smell and I'm
trying to alleviate tension or
awkwardness I've learned throughout the
years that some people are scared to
talk to me or think that I'm like
unapproachable I didn't realize that my
default face was I want to find out if
it's true that if you smile all the time
it makes you happy is happiness just a
muscle contraction okay where my
emotions on my sleeves if I don't like
someone like you'll know but I feel like
it's a skill not like someone and still
be like how are you doing I want to be
able to mask it when I want
I think I'm literally gonna look like
the Joker I'm scared that my smiling
face will look creepy also worried that
I'm gonna feel like a big old phony I'm
gonna go sit down at my desk and just
smile at my computer smiling and working
just smiling smiling smiling smile it's
really nice seeing you happy makes me
happy I walked into the room knows
there's something great and even more
pleasant than usual about him today Liz
was telling me about how her dad forgot
her birthday not a funny story but I had
to smile through and I felt so awkward
right now it doesn't look forced it just
sounds like you're having a good
conversation this is more like I have my
life together and I'm just like a happy
person all the
you know how like when guys on the
street tell you to smile and you tell
them to [ __ ] off I guess they won't do
that anymore cuz they have no reason to
tell me to smile because I'm already
smiling [ __ ] it's a hot day in the
sweater and I'm just smiling like
nothing is wrong
do we look happier as people right now
yeah it's really painful to like have
your lips out like this all the time
other than the cramping that's happening
in my face I think it's kind of
affecting the way I feel
convinces me and my body that I'm having
a great time I do feel like I have like
a lot of energy though which is weird
and I think it's because I can't relax
my face it's really weird smiling
because I'm listening to some super
angsty emo music right now to properly
enjoy my HD music I have to be brooding
I can't do that in the middle of eating
lunch and I realized that I lost my
phone I'm hoping that it's at the office
even though I'm slightly panicking cuz
all my credit cards are in there you
can't tell because I'm smiling Oh
negative thought about something and
then I'll like feel my face kind of melt
into a frown and then I'll pick it back
up into a smile it stops me from having
a negative thought it's like a workout
on my face and my soul just finished a
meeting smiling the whole time the
person giving the presentation did say I
looked creepy but it did feel like a
happier meeting house a smiling nun
stuff it's a little bit disconcerting
because I feel like usually when people
smiles and reaction dissipates sort of
smiling because they just saw you or
they're smiling because something made
them laugh so it's weird to look over
I'm saying hi to people more often I
know what it is I think like having a
big smile might make me a little more
welcoming is the way you perceive me
slightly different with me smelling
completely yeah you just seemed like
warm you just like welcoming I saw you
smiling and then I smiled instantly how
much more welcoming 48 percent enough
for me to talk to you and they're like
hey surprising I'm surprised everybody
thinks I'm like super excited to like
see them but I'm not I'm just smiling
nobody actually leaves me anymore I
tried to say something to somebody and
they were like is this a joke and I was
like no I'm being completely serious
right now
you guys
I'm noticing that all of my interactions
with other people have been pretty great
so far being a smiley person makes all
of your interaction with other human
beings very pleasant who'd have known in
like subtle ways it's helped me kind of
get out in a slump next time you're in a
bad mood
try grinning and see what happens
smiling makes other people smile and it
makes other people happy it makes you
more approachable I got a lot of mixed
reviews on the smiling some people
thought I was more approachable some
people thought it was creepy even though
I did like being more approachable at
the end of the day I'd rather be liked
by a few people that stay real than
liked by a ton of people and be fake
[Music]